frankly if i had to spend all my time
playing golf i'd gotten bored to tears i
needed a diversion so i basically
designed golf courses mostly throughout
my golf career while i was playing
and then when i got finished playing
golf i was a lucky guy because all of a
sudden people still wanted me to do golf
courses even though i wasn't playing and
so it's just a natural extension you've
built a lot of courses it's been a
couple decades since palmia
in cabo tourism is booming luxury hotels
are going up this is one of the fastest
growing cities in mexico can we
attribute that to you did you change
college i'm known by most of my friends
as the guy who ruined cabo who ruined
cabo yeah i mean i came down here in the
early 60s you showed up at the airport
with 20 bucks in your pocket a pair of
sandals a t-shirt and a swimming suit
and you could spend a week well now you
can't get out of the airport for that so
all my friends who came down here and
did that they all said well when you
added golf it changed the whole economic
structure of what went on here in cabo
mother nature did a nice job i've
enjoyed i've been part of it i love the
place i've always loved the place i used
to come down here and fish and now all i
do is come down here and work which is
not too bad this is not a bad office no
it's not too bad so cabo seems to be
doing just fine with respect to golf but
we keep hearing about this global golf
slow down we do have problems with it
golf does take a little bit too long
it's a little bit too expensive it's a
little bit too tough pace of play is a
huge issue we hear about that a lot is
that something you think about when
you're out designing courses
well we try that's what one of the
things that's play it forward key it
forward right yes you know play a
shorter golf course and try to give
people a fairly easy way to play your
golf course if you can do that they'll
play faster you know we've used the 8
inch hole concept i'm a fan of anything
that brings people in the game the big
challenge is how do you do a strong golf
course but make sure that the average
golfer can play it where is demand the
greatest for golf
right now
you know it's really kind of odd because
china is probably the greatest
demand for it but the chinese government
golf is not recognized as a sport they
haven't really set what the rules are
they change the rules they keep changing
the rules every week
and so that's because they don't
understand what what it is
russia is another place that actually is
uh they've got people there that really
love to play golf so they now have
winning some golf courses in their own
area we have several golf courses we're
doing in europe we've got some in
denmark and in latvia and uh we're
working in iran turkmenistan yeah i like
it the olympics to me has been a
tremendous boost for the game of golf
and it'll be boost in underdeveloped
golfing countries
i think the game is growing around the
world and it'll come back in the united
states i heard you don't like the word
retirement no i don't have any desire to
retire i really don't most people work
all their life to retire to play golf i
play golf all my life retire to work and
so my retirement is work and i really
enjoy it